hey guys what's up it's ANCA and for the
next 24 hours I will only be eating
yellow food last time I did only purple
foods for 24 hours it turned out better
than expected so I've asked you guys
what color you wanted me to do NYX based
on the comments I got I think it's safe
to say that yellow has won by far so
yellow foods it is same as last time I'm
gonna try to maintain a very very
balanced diet we're gonna find food that
is naturally yellow but this time before
we go shopping I'm actually gonna look
through my pantry and my fridge to see
if I can find anything that's yellow and
we can start from there I was thinking
that I wouldn't be able to find that
many yellow foods but it turns out
pastas yellow I have my yellow carrots
and my yellow baby carrots from last
time cheese is also yellow I mean
different shades of yellow lemons eggs
and garlic but since we're preparing for
three meals probably a good idea to stop
by the grocery store anyways so let's go
shopping
[Music]
wooden melon
[Music]
yellow peppers first vegetable
I found these pumpkin noodles they love
pretty yellow
[Music]
it is time to make some breakfast I
don't have anything in my wardrobe
that's yellow but I have my gudetama
socks on I also have this little guy
sitting in the background people don't
know who good at Tama is he is a wavy
egg we'll be eating him today I also
have this on my fridge I'm clearly just
trying to find things that are yellow to
fit today's theme breakfast time let's
do it for breakfast I usually eat either
different kinds of fruits or make a
smoothie sometimes I have toast and eggs
because we bought a bunch of fruit at
the grocery store I was thinking of just
making a platter of mixed yellow fruits
and then also making an egg dish to go
with it I would need the golden Kiwi
pineapple mango goat an apple golden
honeydew I'm just gonna cut these all up
and I'll make the eggs on the side a
little meeting sweet what I'm trying to
make is tamagoyaki a japanese-style
omelet I don't have the actual pan so
we're gonna try to do it in this little
round pan of mine I actually also did
them in my bento box video I've just
never had to do them one-handed so I'm
gonna put the camera down and not screw
this up
alright guys breakfast is ready this is
our yellow breakfast for today the melon
didn't turn out to be that yellow I
think it was just the skin the Kiwi is
looking a little bit on the greener side
the eggs turn out pretty good
they're like a pale yellow they would
have probably been more yellow if I only
if I used more yolks mm-hmm it's like
sweet and savory I love that what this
has made me realize is that there are so
many different kinds of fruits there are
yellow
and they're all like really sweet which
is not a bad thing I had no idea golden
apples existed it's really cool to know
that I'm able to sort of eat what I
normally have for breakfast anyways even
on this challenge so I still have a few
minutes before work and I was thinking
at one of the coffee shops that I
normally go to they have this drink
called the tumeric latte that is yellow
so I'm gonna go check that out before we
head to the office
this is the tumeric latte it is now a
yellow color I've never actually had
tumeric before so I don't know how this
is gonna go it's like super aromatic I
sort of kick to it it's actually not bad
that's my yellow drink all right now
back to work there's no catered lunch
day so I'm going to be making my own
lunch but I forgot to bring my pasta so
I'm gonna see if I can find pasta here
in the tasty space boom I have my eggs
the yellow pepper
I have parmesan and butter I was
thinking we can make a carbonara of some
sort vegetarian style in terms of our
pasta problem Elvin donated some
homemade pasta this is pasta dough is
super yellow I'm assuming he only put
egg yolks in here that's perfect I will
have to roll it out now and then we can
go from there
have my pasta strip I want to roll it oh
nice nice nice
here's a pasta strip tada now we're
gonna run it on the other side which is
our fettuccine this is gonna be the
longest lunch break I've ever had I
think this is good enough for one
portion so I'm just gonna leave this
here now pasta is okay we're gonna cut
this pepper up and make the egg and
cheese out
peppers are done I'm gonna set this
aside these are just the egg yolks we'll
just mix this together okay pastas done
put this in here it's tossing this
together add a little bit more water or
a little yellow paste oh yeah there we
go
here it is the carbonara normally I
would put black pepper on this but we
did say yellow challenge so yellow pasta
it is eating time this smells really
good well yeah it's not bad
this is still really creamy the yellow
pepper kind of pulled through too in
terms of sauce this was literally just
egg yolks and Parmesan very yellow if
you say that it's good because your
pasta dole is good I'm gonna shut this
video down do you know what flavor Froyo
we have right now is a yellow we have
Froyo machine
today's flavor is Hawaiian pineapple see
if it really is yellow
you got some Froyo it really is light
yellow I was thinking I'm gonna cut some
bananas up and put that on here to find
a portfolio with banana there's so many
yellow things super refreshing but yeah
lunch was a great success
no cookies for me honey butter chips
also Tooley forgot that I had durian
chips I'm gonna be feasting a little bit
my yellow water bottle right it's sweet
oh my god I forgot how good these burns
I know a lot of people don't like deer
hands but actually one of my favorite
fruits big chunk of meat right
it's unlike anything I've ever had in my
life truly way home rough summer
groceries figured I could make a curry
hopefully works out I'm ready to get
some things chopped up yellow squash
that I just bought yellow carrots corn I
was actually thinking I would put some
apple in this to add a little bit of
sweetness and then we of course have me
Toby go and actually kind of smells like
lemons st i'll just top it off with this
ginger and garlic they're both like a
pale yellow yellow pickled radish which
will also be a side dish honking noodles
this would go well with this gray soup
which I made Ashley yesterday I would
add a little bit of tumeric on it
because that's what gives it more of a
golden hue let's try to put this
together
noodles are about done that's a solid
yellow color this is looking good I'm
just gonna assemble everything really
quickly and then it'll be good for
dinner
I hope you guys are ready for this
because I really think this is yellow
has a get patty and everything sort of
came together and see the radish sit so
Pico at the yellow squash and carrot
golden apple corn mini stir-fry I
started really just leak through
everything yellow together let's give
this a try smells like curry I don't
really taste the pumpkin I have to try
some of that fish roll mmm I love these
you normally eat these with rice but
there Billy goes ooh hmm pretty good
well I'm really hungry if you have
vegetables we have foods we have protein
with carbs I think we have a pretty
balanced meal here just finishing up
some dishes now a lot of dishes to clean
I'm gonna do some work and then probably
time for dessert I got a little carried
away with work
it is now around like 10 p.m. but I mean
my dessert pineapple ice with star fruit
frozen pineapple pineapple bits and a
super creamy here you see the star fruit
and it shaped like a star grew up with
these so it was really cool being able
to find them here so it's kind of sour
it's very very tart the last meal of
today here we go prime brain freeze
material I think today went pretty well
there's a lot of yellow food out there
let me know if you guys want me to do
this again leave a comment below and
based on what I get that will be the
next color I do otherwise peace and see
you guys next time
[Music]